oh that is so good whoa oh my god wow
wow wow wow wow
[Music]
I've taken it as my personal challenge
to bring my burger Vision to today's
guest Elizabeth Olsen a custom menu with
two La icons and a one of a kind Burger
tailor-made for her tastes we fact
checked our sources we did our research
welcome to the Elizabeth Olsen Burger
Omakase
welcome Lizzy it's exciting to have you
here very excited
um we've been preparing weeks for this
this is my sous chef Christian AKA Chef
Riz
do you cook a lot I do I cook a lot
really yes I cook a lot I grow a lot
I've been growing from seed for the
first time this year which has been way
more satisfying than purchasing
seedlings for sure I used to grow it I
got in trouble for it but
I think you can do that now too I feel
like there are some foods I know about
Burgers aren't really something I'm very
knowledgeable about it's an In-N-Out
Burger
yeah we're gonna completely change the
game today well I learned vocab as well
oh totally hopefully when you walk out
of here
you'll be a burger expert okay that
would be really useful yeah so today
what we're going to do is a burger
omokase so it's basically you trusting
us
to take you on a burger Adventure right
above that we're gonna wow you
so our first Burger we're gonna make a
Smash Burger inspired by in and out with
a hint of uh history from uh Oklahoma
wow so one of like the most popular
Burgers I would like to say because of
this show is called the Oklahoma fried
onion burger okay and so we're gonna do
like an in and out meets one of the
oldest classic burgers in the world I
love fried onions oh so this is perfect
before we start let's um while she waits
for this burger to cook it's not fast
food you know we're making it I'll start
off with a little um cocktail and snack
sweet
maybe with grapefruit that sounds
amazing I love grapefruit from Sonoma I
have here fresh citrus from Sonoma is
this from my tree
no it's not
no yeah that's so that's crazy
grapefruit trees
oh my gosh this is a real ladies who
lunch kind of cocktail right you know
you know what I love with cocktails yeah
what do you love corn nuts
oh we know oh we know
Inca corn ER this is what we're talking
about this is all about the this is an
experience and you know I haven't eaten
anything today and half and half so this
is gonna go straight to my head I like
to start with the Buns first and then we
have our onions here sweet onions and
we're we're cutting them like super
super thin almost
translucent I really feel like I'm just
this is this is my favorite afternoon
right now we're challenging every fine
dining restaurant right now because yeah
easily this is this is Hospitality at
its greatest shut up yes it usually uses
like a regular American hamburger bun
but today I had my Baker at bread bar
make these special brioche buns just for
you they smell amazing smells so good
yeah it doesn't need any butter because
there's so much butter in it already
yeah I'm gonna do one patty regular and
then we're gonna smash it so this is
probably what people think is like the
most trendiest way of making a burger
yes but in fact it's one of the old
oldest methods of Making burgers so you
can get really good in my yard
um
caramelization of beef for our second
Patty this is like a George moats Hefty
amount of onions
yeah so this is gonna be the way they
originally do it in Oklahoma then we'll
smash that through
oh wow and what kind of
um ground meat are you using it's
brisket short rib and Chuck have you
ever had animal style burgers before I'm
not sure you throw out a little mustard
onto the Patty big life hack mustard
seared it adds flavor this is special
because
now this onion is going to start cooking
I always like to use one single piece of
cheese and put the hot Patty this looks
so good that's cool right yeah okay so
this is done it's time for you to make
your own special sauce because in
essence what makes in and out awesome is
the spread yes and so we're gonna give
you an opportunity because we know you
love condiments okay is it just relish
ketchup and mayonnaise usually but today
we have a ton of stuff like what do we
have wow so we know you uh like homemade
Mayo so I went and made mayo oh gosh
yeah so here we have caramelized onions
yeah chopped chilies ketchup spicy brown
mustard classic yellow yeah sweet relish
Yep Hot Sauce paprika tomato paste okay
well I definitely need ketchup the sweet
relish yes good choice and
that must work would I add just more
tomato paste to make it earthy instead
sweet absolutely maybe I'll do a little
bit of that
yeah chopped chilies is where it's at
for me I think you're good
it's good color yeah it looks like a
really awesome Special Sauce some
pickles I like a good amount of pickles
I don't know about you I love pickles
yeah okay and then we're gonna go with
some lettuce Iceberg we're going Iceberg
and we're not putting tomatoes I don't
love tomatoes on Burgers wow there it is
the beautiful so beautiful La in and out
okay okay see Lizzy Olsen
question going about putting a mouth on
this thing would you like smash it yes
smash the burger and then I just make a
real big face yes it's okay it's
supposed to be ugly delicious
hahaha
so that's a bite that is so good
oh my God you have the beautiful buttery
bun you have the crunch of the lettuce
the sweetness of the pickles the my yard
and the onions
glue it all together is really a good
move okay I'm glad you like chopped
Chili's in the sauce right yeah but also
having like just Cracked Pepper that I
can
taste is like bringing out all of the
creaminess in some way I don't know how
to explain it I'm not you just did okay
the next Burger that we're doing yes is
another one there's another one because
this is so good it's another LA classic
but this is something that you'll find
on the sandwich section of a menu
wow
here we go Burger number two this burger
is the patty melt oh which was invented
by Bob's Big Boy no tiny nailer from
tiny nails
and this one's All About The Bread I
love bread there's this big debate about
everything in a Patty metal okay the
bread the meat everything so this burger
is going to be a Choose Your Own
Adventure okay okay you're gonna have to
pick
what bread to use what cheese used what
kind of meat to use Okay Christian tell
me what we have we have bread bar baked
sourdough
or seeded Rye I think I'm gonna do
sourdough because my favorite kind of
Rye is more of like the nordicry we have
cheddar and provolone cheddar is
something I eat all the time okay okay
sometimes I like a butcher blend okay
it's a lot more rich and then we have
just Chuck which is like what you find
in an everyday burger then I think we
should go with Chuck Chuck it is I heard
that okay let's start I'm just waiting
for some butter
oh
butter is here
we're ready to go
beautiful now we're throwing on The
Oblong Patty I have a show coming out
yes uh for HBO Max Called Love and Death
oh my God I can't wait and I grind meat
in it and I just put that together right
now do you
grind your own meat yes we do you do yes
so you make your own butcher's blend oh
yeah okay 100 you have to come by I will
shoot the place down and it's like one
of these oh no I wish
to do that yeah because I was doing in
real time with like a vintage one and it
was very challenging to really get the
meat coming out of it now you can't wait
to watch me grind some meat so this is
the secret right I'm letting it hang a
little bit this is a trick that I
learned from casells uh in Koreatown
yeah we call it cheese Wing so we have
caramelized onions here I love to put a
little bit bit of coriander in it those
wings look really fun it's like a bow
tie right and then next is toppings
attached chilies okay
yes
it's uh Indonesian style like a it's
like a dried sambal oh I want that okay
flavor bomb would you like your pickled
chicken or sandwich or on the side on
the side please we're crisping it up
look at it it's got Wings careful just
like that
oh wait look at the cross action hey
you're welcome internet is that another
thing on the internet I like to dip it
yeah you should do cross sections and
the push
um
we have Ranch but then we also have
Boston sauce I literally this is the
kind of like my my favorite like hot
sauce uh in the game right now okay I'll
do that oh perfect that was easy I know
what Ranch tastes like that's no fun
so enjoy should I eat the cheese first
or wait yeah try it okay
not too sharp on the cheddar it's so
good yes
[Music]
if you can tell the bread is really good
by the sound of the crisp that sauce is
so fire right he makes the sauce you
make it yes whoa it's pretty incredible
what else can we do it's number three I
really don't know what else you could do
because this is already so incredible
foreign
this is going to be a burger that's
inspired but on the count of one two
three I'm gonna tell you my favorite
pasta dish and then you're gonna tell me
your favorite pasta dish ready okay one
two three
what kind of noodle I'm a fusilli dude
you like concealy yeah I love the sauce
oh
oh we're both bucatina gals let's go
okay so silly thank you we're gonna turn
your favorite dish
into a burger wow wow okay so that's
what we have here
is
what we did was we made a couple we made
a couple of sauces
and then we made so basically we have
kachoy Pepe and like uh parmesan
provolone provolone heavy cream heavy
cream situation where and we so we used
our own special Chef technique to make a
sliceable cheese yeah based off of your
favorite pasta dish
we're gonna make you a burger with our
Credo meat cheese bun amazing so this is
our our custom made sesame seed bun oh
wow is it like a brioche with Sesame
kind of it's similar it's more like a
Hokkaido milk bun I love milk toast we
can't just have regular beef we have to
have like something amazing this is rib
eye cut oh love ribeye
I like to just season one side because
sometimes it gets too salty and then is
that what you were doing with the other
ones as well yeah I only season one side
because it's relatively thin and also
you want the burnt you want the beef to
taste like beef yes great but see oh the
nooks the crannies the my arms the my
yard the caramelization that's what you
want our cachoe Pepe cheese that we made
so cool amazing and then just to kind of
like more catio get it more catchyo
we're going to add a little bit of this
we're going to bring out the Sears all
wow
it acts like a salamander when you say
salamander I imagine a slime a lizard
lizard that lives in my yard my yard
boom fresh Cracked Pepper that's it
simple beautiful meat cheese bun
when I have a burger yeah especially a
thicker Patty Burger I kind of like to
enjoy it with some wine you guys this is
too much call before two
straight out of Chateau Robert
[Laughter]
explain to us what we have here you have
um my husband's Cowboy wine
yes I'm telling you we have pulled out
all the stops this day is for you and
this is how we're gonna end our Burger
so funny you guys I I feel like I don't
know how you managed to get this without
me knowing oh I'm always home and I'm
always nosy so this is
um a blend that we can never make again
and so this is a cab uh Zen and
tempranillo blend
and you don't have to like it that's the
joy of making your own wine Cheers
Cheers Cheers yes
we never made labels so it's all
tanning tape
damn that's actually pretty damn good
yeah it's not bad right that's actually
pretty damn good
uh
I think we nailed it that is so good it
really tastes like I'm eating Pepe sauce
that is so cool so we turned it into a
sliceable cheese
[Music]
one more thing because you've completed
the master class thank you you've gone
through the burger Omakase she's no
longer a novice I'm no longer enough
she's no longer a novice she's now a
burger expert we have
[Music]
no more golden tongs no more golden
spatula we have
a real Bonafide practical trophy Burger
bucket list I would like to thank Alvin
and Christian for a delightful day
eating burgers and teaching me how I can
make burgers better even though they'll
never taste this good and I would like
to thank Justin who I went to high
school with who produces Anthony who
produces this show and I'd like to thank
Jessica duby I'm so proud that we that
we are still able to show the human
figure and and the plates and the bowls
boom in lieu of writing check her out
beautiful Burger Omakase all about you
thanks for coming this is really just
such a treat I'll never leave cheers
and cheers to pedestrian Burger bucket
list Burger Omakase with Lizzie Olson my
boy Christian we Out Burger show baby oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello Internet it's your boy Alvin kylon
make sure you hit that like button smash
that subscribe button ring that
notification Bell if not for me
for the burgers
this show that show him the wine